wir schauen mit sorge auch auf den
leuchtturm von bremerhaven der steht
nämlich wie sie hier unschwer erkennen
können seit dem morgen gewaltig schief
ja nicht nur das sondern eher droht auch
umzufallen der grund die hafenmole die
nordmole ist in teilen eingestürzt also
abgesagt und auf ihr steht eben dieser
leuchtturm der nun der schiefe
leuchtturm des bremerhaven ist bild
reporter peter will ist genau da für uns
vor ort später beschreibt uns diese lage
wie konnte es überhaupt dazu kommen und
was sind jetzt die nächsten schritte für
die nächsten stunden
valentina diese mode ist auf holzpfählen
gestützt und diese holzpfähle sind im
laufe der vielen jahre
verrottet durchgegangen also sind sehr
dünn geworden ich habe bilder davon
gesehen das ist also im letzten jahr
schon sehr kritisch aussah und ja jetzt
ist es von kollabiert und über nacht ist
das ding dann sozusagen ein gekracht ich
höre auch tatsächlich hinter mir immer
mal wieder irgendwas ins wasser setzen
also es ist auf jeden fall bewegung drin
das ist ja ein wahrzeichen da ein
bremerhaven werden kann mal nachgeschaut
das ding gibt es seit 1917 immer wieder
sind auch schiffe dagegen gefahren im
nebel hat ihm alles nichts ausgemacht im
leuchtturm der hat standgehalten wind
und wetter und jetzt plötzlich der krach
taste 1 und der leuchtturm der droht
einzustürzen umzufallen ich kann mir
ganz schwer vorstellen peter dass da
irgendwie mit manneskraft oder mit kraft
von maschinen der heute wieder
aufgerichtet werden kann wieder gerade
gestellt werden kann man wird ihn
vermutlich abreißen müssen oder
jacke also im moment ist es so dass
natürlich alles gesperrt ist die
hafeneinfahrt ist gesperrt die ausfahrt
ist gesperrt die schiffe liegen fest ich
habe eben dem einzigen kampf zwischen
bremerhaven gesprochen der an seiner
in seinem geschäft halt hängt und jetzt
nicht rausfahren kann macht mir große
vorwürfe an die verantwortlichen weil
das bauwerk schon länger marode ist das
ist auch der zugang ist gesperrt man
kommt da so gar nicht hin er soll auch
verlegt werden aber es ist halt alles
noch so wie es war und jetzt ist das
ding tatsächlich langsam so marode dass
ist zusammenkracht und ja man
hoffentlich nur das ist jetzt nicht
einstürzt und man überlegt jetzt die man
das sichern konnte peter will vielen
dank für deine einschätzung in wir
beobachten die lage weiterhin ganz genau
[Musik]